hey welcome back to another episode of
stuntman react we are here with a legend
on the couch today we have JJ Perry
who's joining us
get over here this is where I got
brought on to double Johnny Cage I
actually broke a rib drill Yeah I broke
a rib doing that one I've been very
fortunate to fall into the stunt
business in a fun way being a stunt man
to being a fight coordinator being a
stunt coordinator to being a director
and we're gonna watch stuff from
kirasawa
that's a real Arrow getting shot in
because they didn't do it in reverse
trust me no no all the way up to John
Wick 2.
got John Wick 2 he said to me how can we
make two better than one yeah we have a
banger for you today so be without
further Ado let's jump in
[Music]
oh let's do it armor of God
when I saw this movie the first time it
really really moved me because for me
it's amazing wire works and this is
where you could just see that there's no
pads on their arms nope you know and I'm
not convinced those aren't Hong Kong
stunt guys right there 20 frames per
second yeah and this is a nasty wreck to
watch this three-quarter boom split it
and right to your Dome
now he jumps down
right here boom
oh man this one is great yeah it's so
good he started to bend his knees a
little bit you could tell he's getting
he's loading it and he's getting ready
to go to his limit and he bends a little
bit right here and now he's into the
gooch and we let him out interesting so
what's happening is effectively like a
yo-yo this the stunt person's jumping
out and they the cord only has a certain
length yeah they're picked here they're
picked here and it goes through their
legs that's why you call it a gooch it
goes through the little ding dings
how hard you think The Shins are making
contact I think he's smacking the snot
out of her or whoever that is yeah but I
also feel like they had on really heavy
hard shin pads for that to motivate that
because that's I can tell you those are
two they've got some old dynees or old
shins on and they're just sending that
round kick you could see they dug it up
and fluffed up the ground they probably
had a little mattress down there or
something but I can tell you they
probably didn't get that in one you know
they were like okay one more time
because Jackie's notorious for going 35
40 times right respect though like he
needs to get what he wants as a director
because he directed this film and he's
got the scars to prove it yeah did he
break
first time he cut his hair yeah if you
watch day shift in the apartment we we
called it the armor of God I did homage
to this shot
you know he jumps down Jamie Shin checks
this guy it's because I love this shot
so much
love that slow motion shot now he goes
underneath kicks her in the booty and we
do that frappe right there you have to
remember back then when they were doing
wire work it was hard for them to hide
the wires because you can't like I don't
know if they had rotoscope they just had
to light it yeah but you also see the
the lines in the back of the set yeah it
will help hide that and I that's got to
be some sort of Gooch but you can see
the wire if you step through it right it
is it's Gotta Be It's gotta be it's got
to be when Jackie Chan started as a
stunt man and Jackie Chan I don't think
gets as much credit as he deserves for
the way that we do things now he started
as a stun man which we can relate to
right why he wanted to become an actor
but he became a director which means he
took control of everything that he was
doing from the way it was shot to the
way it was cut to the way it was blocked
so from like 81 when he was doing the
yeah yeah and there was a switch happen
when he got to direct his first few
movies and he had this team of dudes
around him that would just kill
themselves but they didn't have any
visual effects no they didn't have any
damn neoprene to pad you up let's put
some deep green on the floor they're
like neoprene what's neoprene because I
worked in Hong Kong in 97 96 and 97. it
was different you know they didn't have
shackles they would take the wire and
tie it on you you know like so the stuff
they were doing they were shooting with
one or two cameras man respect like some
of the best action Cinema in my humble
opinion was Chan and then you've also
got John Wu that comes with the best
some of the best gun stuff originally
but Hong Kong was churning out some
amazing stuff John Wick
or do you want to just give me a gun do
you know Chad sahowski and you worked on
the John Wick franchise right yeah so
when I got out of the army Chad
stachowski is one of the first people
that I met we were both Fighters at the
time when Chad got John Wick 2 he called
me to be the stunt coordinator and he
said to me how can we make two better
than one and of course the answer was we
have to make Reeves better so I wanted
to get him out of that isosceles stance
the robotic style over over robotics so
we took him out to this gun range called
Terran tactical in Simi Valley where we
got him going on three gun you know what
I mean because now you got to see which
Target you're shooting as opposed to one
two three one now it's one two one two
one two you know you're moving and going
from rifle to Pistol reloading going
back to primary reloading going to the
shotgun reloading and being able to
correct your own malfunctions so we
would set up a course for him you know
Taran would run it first and we would
make it difficult for him to do but then
once we did three of those we would make
it another course we'd say okay this is
three takes you get three takes to get
this right I would put a dummy round in
his piss so he would get a malfunction
which in the middle of his set you would
have to correct that right so his Target
acquisition like his ability to pick up
targets became ridiculously fast
you know for me as a stunt coordinator
my job is to create enriching
experiences to help the actors and the
talent and the stunt Department be as
proficient as they can on the day that
they show up to do it's exactly the same
as planning in the military planning as
a fighter and that's the same as
planning as a stunt coordinator who
would have known being in the military
would have been such good prerequisite
for being a stunt quarter wow I got
lucky yeah so the only difference is
everything is scripted in the movies and
nothing is scripted in the Army and you
have to clean them up you have to do a
lot more cleaning in the army
in the movies
[Music]
are you guys working with blank firing
guns you guys working with airsoft guns
Just inner rubber solid plug guns that
don't emit any combustion from the front
but they cycle it's a half load so the
gun Cycles it's there is an explosion in
the gun to make it cycle properly it's a
blank but nothing comes out the front so
you can point blanket and it cycles and
Brass comes out that's dope so because a
lot of the cues for the stuntmen come
from they're counting the shots yeah
when you're doing a long take shot
number seven means you gotta step out
shot number nine means you gotta step
out right so we need something that will
report you know so that's what it is and
also doing all the muzzle flash and
blood hits in post even if he throws a
shot that doesn't work you can change it
and make it work for camera and I think
this is a new standard because when
you're putting Blanks on people you know
when you're a stunt coordinator you say
oh we're gonna put blanks that means the
Wardrobe has to have three costumes yeah
now you do the blanks oh it didn't work
we have to go again you've just lost 20
minutes on the turnaround yep then we do
it again it doesn't organ is another 20
minutes you spend an hour on one setup
for one blank where you could have just
done it with visual effects and I'm a
huge fan of this
so you know Keanu Reeves is a little bit
older yeah and you know he's a lead
actor he's doing a lot of performing on
doing everything except for the wrecks
maybe it didn't happen but I assume
there's a moment where like you know he
took a bonk or a bump or something
happened that you know everything comes
to stop for a second what happens then
do you just you just wait do you try to
recover do you move to shooting
something else like because every minute
is expensive when you have 150 people
yeah I mean there's a stunt coordinator
in my job is to manage talent and manage
stunts like somebody gets hurt on my
watch you know like there's there's two
versions of that hurt means you can work
again right injured means you can't
injured means you're getting in the
ambulance you're getting sewn up and as
a stun performer uh you're gonna get
injured you mostly fight work you're
just gonna get punched in the face or
fall and bang your head but you're also
going to do big stunts like can in a car
or get thrown downstairs get hit by a
car to jump off a building or get set on
fire where you could get injured or
killed so when it comes to something
like this when you have a star what we
did was we really spent a lot of time
perfecting six judo throws or five Judo
throws and six or seven transitions in
Jiu Jitsu now the throws he's pitching
those throws you know what I mean he's
not catching those throws he gets hooked
around a little bit but for the most
part he's sending people to the ground
or he's doing a ballistic throw where he
uses the the arm that he's taking down
as a lever to go to the next shot like
half your job is protecting everyone and
sometimes you have to protect people
from themselves and that doesn't always
go over well but that's your job and
they hire stunt coordinators and you
know this ski to blame us we will be the
first ones to get pulled into a
deposition if somebody gets killed like
so when you're offering your services on
a job that's dangerous you have to know
that this very well could be your last
job ever God forbid you hurt or kill
anyone one of your friends or anyone on
set or crew but like that's that's how
it goes yep you know like that's part of
the job and that's what it is that's why
they're hires if they didn't if it
wasn't risky we would be out of a job
that's true
[Music]
oh no this is like the first good video
game movie yes in my opinion this is the
very first Mortal Kombat and this is
where I got brought on to double Johnny
Cage but I was fighting tatsuro koike
from the alpha stunt Team Alpha stunts
is the guy who did the uh they all did
the Power Rangers
get down here and then we round kicked
this is the boo account
and now we go on a little ride
oh my God and then we do uh
I'm assuming it's multiple yeah multiple
takes I actually broke a rib drill this
yeah I broke a rib doing that one wow
because one of them was hard and I
remember being gutted and that was the
end of it it was the last day of the
last thing I've been knocked out for my
head kick before in Korea right but I'd
never been ever been down from a body
shot in a tournament I've been dropped
from body shots in gym from heavyweights
and stuff but I couldn't breathe yeah
and I didn't panic I was like okay we
should get your together like
everybody's watching be cool
laughs
Jeff Yamada comes over his Studio okay I
was like
I'm not sure yet and he goes okay you
know it's cool you know and so on I made
myself kind of Wiggle up and I don't
know if you've ever had a broken rib bro
yeah
[Music]
no dog like you can't cough sneeze fart
poop none of that dude like you're like
so I took one of those neoprene wraps
and wrapped it up and tried to pretend
like I was okay but then send me the
hospital got an x-ray and they said no
you have a broken rib buddy and then
going on to do the next one and then
getting invited to the TV series to
double Kung Lao and to be Sub-Zero which
was super cool like look I I kind of
wanted to be an actor when I was young
but you know for me it was like oh let's
do some fun but now I'm I'm chub
zero
I'm not Sub-Zero I'm chub zero
[Music]
we filmed Mortal Kombat 2 in London
Jordan and Thailand but we had a great
time doing this you know this is the
first fight we shot me and Lynn
rehearsed this and we busted each other
up Lynn really put it on me dog there's
he smacked me good a couple times with
those big things yeah it was this one
right here where he got me
right in the mush
yeah
and that's a work finish JJ get in your
next costume
there you go so for me it was a lot of
fun like being a part of that back in
the day we ran this Gambit of TV shows
like Buffy Angel VIP 100 episodes of
Walker Walker was like a stunt man's
dream I'm from Texas right they love the
teamsters down there well that JJ he
knows karate
working on TV you have to move very
quickly you know you have to do an
episode in seven days yeah but this for
me was a stunt man's dream because there
was always a fight or two it's always a
car chase there's always a big stun
explosions
maybe does it dive Justin does a dive
here but dive and shoot I told him to do
the job behind the building for him sick
like I remember a diving pistol shot any
day all right
don't put fire in the background and
some doves in the foreground and it
would have been like John Woo baby are
there any misconceptions you think
people might have about these fight
scenes well listen man it's
1997 8-ish and it's TV so for what we
were doing there it was still it was
still quite you know still quite
intricate and it's for Pure enjoyment
it's a popcorn show man I had so much
fun doing it and I don't regret her I'm
not ashamed of any of it that was
amazing I would love to see some heavy
visual effects stunts with some super
realistic stuff keep it in the frame
y'all can't wait to see the comments any
projects coming out like what's the next
question
probably going to direct this movie with
Batista I'm leaving in two weeks called
Killer's game for Lionsgate and then we
are hopefully uh gonna do night shift
yeah we just put a pitch out there and
we're hoping to get the rider that did
John Wick forward and it's humbling to
me that I've had this kind of success
and I've been able to Tool in with some
of the great people that I've been able
to Tool in with and I'm super honored
that you guys would have me on your show
and thank you all so much I'm super
honored you would join us here thank you
Legend I hope I didn't stop
my wife told me to tell you guys to make
sure that I don't suck so you know
hopefully great
yeah yeah heck yeah what a great note to
end this episode on
bye everybody
peace